your questions about the omicron variant
it's got a lot of people worried this
holiday season so we asked you to tell
us what you would like to know and you
did and we thank you for that our chief
medical correspondent dr john lepuc is
back thanks for coming back to answer
some of your questions hello again dr
lapook how are you doing hi
i'm doing great good to have you hi
john don't sound so excited it's not too
exciting all right we got questions from
the viewers all right so we need to
highlight i'm still excited about
princeton that's like oh yeah okay okay
good good good i mean you were a little
more excited talking to gail earlier in
the show i know i'm just nate but let's
jump right in though um so
so with christmas christmas approaching
alex asked this is it safe to do indoor
activities if you're distancing in all
school also masking should we go back to
the level of precaution we had in 2020
what do you say
well you know the big thing is that the
masking i think if you're wearing an n95
indoors you're going to be okay i think
what most people want to do is can they
be with loved ones indoors without
masking
and that's a little bit more complicated
i mean i just uh
spoke this morning i reached out to tony
thaucy and he said to try to avoid
large gatherings like say 20 30 40
people because that increases the risk
um rachelle willenski you know you don't
have to be smart you just have to know
somebody smart so i reached out to her
and she said
it's very important the week before you
know what's your risk been there because
that's where you can pick it up with a
with a incubation period of say you know
one to four days that kind of thing once
you're inside you know if the second
before you if you have the testing we've
talked about these fast tests if right
before you take off your mask and go
inside you do a test and it's negative
that gives you another layer of
protection and of course once you're
inside ventilation uh air filtration if
you have an air filter all those steps
we've been talking about you know they
add layers of protection
boy i thought you raised a really good
point when you said watch your behavior
before the holiday people need to pay
attention to that this next question
john comes from michelle i love this
question because i was thinking the
exact same thing michelle your question
is seems like we're hearing about a lot
more breakthrough cases even after the
booster shots with omicron does that
match the data and i would add this how
concerned should we be about this
well it's very clear that we're seeing a
lot of breakthrough infections and in
fact i you know i'm an internist and a
gastroenterologist in the past week i've
had about 10 people who were fully
vaxxed and boosted who got infected from
other people who appeared to be fully
vaxxed and boosted and they're all doing
fine right now i mean i don't think
that's going to be for everybody but um
so far it looks like the people who are
getting the breakthrough infections who
are fully boosted that's very important
vaccine boosted are doing better um in
general than say you know in the past
and we know what we really want to guard
against is people out there saying oh
i'm hearing that this is a milder
version of of of the virus
and so i'm not going to get vaccinated
do not do that because we don't know to
what extent uh the in in scotland and in
south africa the fact that it looks like
it might be a little milder is because
they had underlying immune underlying
immunity or vaccination or that the
virus itself was a little bit less
virulent so please get vaccinated and
boosted we'll say it over and over again
that you have waning immunity especially
against omicron when you get boosted it
really brings it up significantly you
can't say that enough a lot of people
rushing now to get boosted and when you
get the booster how soon before it takes
effect if i get it today i already have
mine but if i got it today when does it
kick in and i'm covered
you know i asked the cdc that yesterday
and within 48 hours you start to get an
increase in the titers in the amount of
neutralizing antibodies of course i
think you know within a couple of weeks
you really you're really up there but uh
it acts very quickly so it's it's never
too late go get it
uh dr lapook you mentioned underlying
immunity you've got a question from a
viewer named kate related to that given
how contagious and widespread omicron is
kate would like to know is there such a
thing as herd immunity
i love that question because you know
this has been a moving goal post right
we're saying uh how much do we need in
order to be immune to have the hurt
immunity and it may be that we're
heading towards it right now with a
combination of so many people getting
infected plus the vaccinations and the
boosting we might be heading towards
herd immunity and wouldn't that be great
i mean one of the hypothesis and it's
just a hypothesis you know to make
people feel a little better with
everything that's going on is that we're
going to see a big upslope uh because
omicron's so contagious but it's
possible it's possible that it's going
to then start to go down faster like
we're seeing in south africa
it's going to be a bumpy ride there are
going to be a lot of hospitalizations
because even if in one person the risk
is lower of hospitalization you can have
so many millions of people infected
you're going to have pressure on the
hospital system plus you have flu and
other things that are happening so we're
worried about that but then on the off
ramp maybe we get to that endemic status
where tony thought she's been talking
about wanting to get to less than 10 000
cases a day it's kind of in the rear
view mirror it's going to always be with
us but at least we don't have to be just
so staring it right in the face
i like when you call uh anthony apache
tony fauci dr lapu it's the most
distinguished tony in america i think
he's our top tony i'll go with him
all right
john thank you so much we appreciate you
happy holidays